if i had created a website with this
many problems i'd kill myself do you
have a question kelly yeah i have a lot
of questions number one how dare you i
just want you to know that i will be
mean to jessica if you want me to be oh
no no it's fine kelly it's really no
problem i was already planning on being
mean to her that's okay i don't want you
to do that yup
game on
it
[Laughter]
oh jessica did you just fart
and that is how it's done
could you scoot over you're on my dress
i thought you're not supposed to wear
white to a wedding i know but there was
an emergency
i look really good in white
excuse me miss bennett may have a word
okay
uh can it be in private don't worry it's
not about you
as minority executive i think it's my
responsibility to let you know that gabe
is gross i don't think it's professional
that he was sleeping with a receptionist
and then when aaron dumped him so that
she could be with andy he became a total
crazy stalker psycho got to catch a
plane
oh hey gabe i'm sorry we we didn't get
you a cake or anything we're gonna miss
you oh well i'm still the corporate
liaison to the branch you are not
leaving not giving me a hug
okay you know what you don't need to
make that sound i'm sorry you were just
a lot bonier than i thought you were
gonna be
it's so funny why is daryl here he works
in the warehouse i invited him it's not
a party daryl back downstairs this isn't
information you need this information
here yeah you're right i don't need this
okay
[Music]
so
how are you awesome i am dating a lot of
guys good a lot black guys mostly
kelly what
i want you to tell me that you care
about me that is what i want kelly i'm
your boss now okay you can't keep
talking to me like i'm your boyfriend oh
big strong man fancy new whatever i
don't think you ever cared about me i
never cared about you six months ago
karen filippelli sent me an email asked
me out i said no because i was committed
to our relationship well i hope you're
still committed because i'm pregnant
and guess what buddy i am keeping it
okay
okay do you feel prepared to help me
raise a baby
i can't talk about this right now okay
after work we'll go out to dinner we'll
talk about it then okay
we have a date
it's whom when it's the object of the
sentence and who when is the subject
that sounds right well it sounds right
but is it how did ryan use it as an
object as an object chinese me as an
object fumble means steak
right
par for the course is a golf term it
means right on track
uh below par means worse
wait that should mean better that
doesn't make sense what about second
base
like if michael said he got to second
base with you does that mean you like
closed a deal excuse me
i mean that's a baseball term right
i don't know what michael was
talking about i don't know
hey kelly screw you
excuse me that is no way to address the
superior oh yeah screw you too come on
where are you
let's do this thing
come on come on out
i can't believe they're gonna fight over
me
i guess people have fewer choices as
they get older
what do you mean you have plans tonight
i have my daughter tonight we're renting
charlotte's web well you have to make a
choice it's either your daughter or me
my daughter
yeah
i see how it is
oops
that was cold
what has two skinny chicken legs and
sucks at ping pong hi kelly guess whose
boyfriend it is i don't want to guess
i'll give you a hint it's not my
boyfriend
i think it's a guy over here
i don't talk trash i talk smack they're
totally different trash talk is all
hypothetical like your mom is so fat you
could eat the internet but smack talk is
happening like right now
like you're ugly and i know it for a
fact so i get the evidence right there
wow it's so
sexy you look so hot it's really
something it's too much what i'm gonna
return it no you have to keep it today
just see how you feel
hey hi
you look nice
thanks
isn't that like your third soda today
okay you know what fine i'm not daryl
and thank god i'm not daryl could you
for once just let us enjoy a party
instead of making it about all your
issues
okay everyone i've tallied the votes and
the winner of the costume celebration
spectacular and the scranton
wilkes-barre coupon book oscar martinez
[Applause]
if i have to vote for someone i don't
want it to be someone who can beat me
can you stop micromanaging i know you
could do this you're yelling what are
you guys doing this girl was really rude
to me at the mall so i created a fake im
account from a hot guy at her high
school and now i'm trying to make her
anorexic tell her everyone in homeroom
thinks she's fat oh that is so good i've
never heard you talk that much
i thought it was kelly are you kidding i
would never have done that it was
pathetic though no that's pam hey kelly
oh so jealous of your boobs
thank you
um listen i just wanted to confirm that
you're not coming to the wedding which
is totally understandable and more than
fine
is ryan going
i don't know he has an rsvp yet here's
the deal i really want to go but i'm not
going to go if ryan doesn't go because
it's kind of a waste of time
that came out wrong it would be awesome
if you could try to get him to go
because i'd really like to be there to
support jim
caffe disco really crappy disco
you're bad
i have made a list of people that i
would make out with before i would make
out with michael scott a turtle
a fridge
anybody from the warehouse
a wood chipper
kevin
a candle
and lord voldemort anyway happy birthday
michael yeah
you'd be so lucky
good one oh my god are you so excited
for tonight i'm so excited you guys are
gonna click i can feel it so what are
you wearing
this
you look so pretty
thank you
look i know the reason that you guys
became accountants is because you're not
good at interacting with people but
guess what from now on you guys are no
longer losers so give yourselves a round
of applause
you should come to my art show by the
way oh
art show i mean it's not a big deal
but i think a lot of people from the
office are gonna be there
oh
yeah
definitely i'll be there for sure
i can't believe that ryan is not back
yet where could they be
cells take a long time oh my god i'm so
worried
i'm sure dwight will protect him i don't
know dwight's so weird
he's not weird he's just individualistic
no he's a freak you're a freak
you